Feehan ممكن ملصق شائع الآن
Alamo Doyle Maharaja ليس سينما عام
Naruto Judah عائلة مهراجا ليس
دهنيًا أو فلمنكيًا سأكون Madhu Ryan
McLean جميل الهتال
mahajanas أمي من الحمل والقصيدة ماريا في
أم rakia وسينما Mahajan في
التلغراف في خزائن Mirat آنا  ماذا
انتظروا ساعة
ألما درة الفلستين 2 تعني جوني
تماري عندما يتشدد سوني
واها تاتا فولي بي بي ،
الملصق الشيطاني دونا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على وجودك معنا اليوم ، أعتقد أنك شكرًا
لك على استضافتنا ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أكون
هنا نريد العودة  في الوقت المناسب
وأسألك عن الهدف من وراء بدء
فلسطين الحقيقية هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، أولاً ، هي
موطن لي وبالنسبة لنا جميعًا في
الفريق نشأ بعضنا هنا ، فقد
بدأوا جميعًا في صيف 2014 في
يوليو عندما كان هناك  حرب في الحوزة
وأتذكر مشاهدة الأخبار وكل
يوم أرى الناس يعانون
وشعرت أنني جالس هنا وأنا
مرتاح لما يمكنني فعله وأتذكر
ذلك ، لقد فكرت في نفسي في عملي اليومي
كنت أعمل على برمجة الأفلام
ورأيت مدى ضخامة أحداث الفيلم المؤثر
، ورأيت كيف جلبت أكبر
عدد من الأشخاص ، لكنني فكرت لماذا لم
تنظم سلسلة من عروض الأفلام
حول الأفلام الفلسطينية حتى يتمكن الناس من
فهم أن هناك  أكثر إلى
أبعد من مجرد الحرب
والمعاناة التي نواصل رؤيتها ، لذا
فإن الفكرة هي أن نظهر لك
فلسطين من واقع حقيقي كما في فيلم
حقيقي ولكن أيضًا في نفس الوقت ترى الحياة الواقعية ،
لذا انظر إلى البرنامج من اليوم
الأول حتى  إصدار السلسلة ، كيف
تطورت وتطورت أولاً وقبل كل شيء انتقلنا
من فترة أسبوع واحد إلى الآن نحن
نقوم بعشرة أيام ، ثم قبل
أن نقوم بفحص واحد فقط في اليوم ، لدينا الآن
عرضان على الأقل في اليوم لذلك
هل يمكنك إخبارنا مثل بعض
النقاط البارزة لما سيتم عرضه في
هذا العام ، لذا نحاول هذا العام مثل كل عام
أن يكون كل فيلم يتم عرضه
يغطي موضوعًا مختلفًا تمامًا
على سبيل المثال سيعرض
فيلمًا واحدًا فقط يغطي  سيكون الموضوع حول
الجدار الفاصل موضوعًا واحدًا
سيغطي ربما سجن الأطفال
لدينا فيلم وثائقي سيغطي أيضًا
تمكين المرأة
وتقرير المصير والعديد من
أفلامنا هذا العام لم يتم عرضها في
دبي بعد ولأسفل وسؤالي الأخير
بالنسبة لك ، فإن أهمية وجود مثل
هذا المهرجان مليء لماذا
تعتقد أنه من المهم إقامة مثل هذا الحدث
في هذه اللحظة ، فهذا الوقت مهم
لأنني أعني أننا بحاجة إلى التعبير عن
أصوات الناس التي لا تُسمع ، أعني
أننا عادة ما نسمع  هذه الأشياء
في الأخبار لكنني أعني حقيقة ذلك أنه
ربما لا يشاهد الجميع الأخبار
الشباب مثل
- تعلمون البث المباشر يشاهدون Netflix أو
تعلمون مشاهدة برنامج على Apple TV
وأعني أن الطريقة التي نضعها فيه هي
أننا  حاول أن تجعله أيضًا جذابًا
جدًا للشباب وللجيل المسن
وليس سياسيًا
ولكنه دبلوماسي ناعم وهو بطريقة ما هو
كيف يمكننا توصيل رسالتنا إلى هناك
ومشاركتها  قصص
وطريقة غير سياسية
وتنسيقات غير مقاومة ، أعني أننا
نرى أنها مهمة لأن الكثير من
صانعي الأفلام أيضًا هذا العام ليسوا
مسلحين ، وكثير من المخرجين الذين لدينا
في تشكيلة الفريق ليسوا في
الأصل أصلاً  العربي الذي كان
ممتعًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا وكان من
قبيل الصدفة أنها مثيرة وآمل
أن تأخذها وتتكيف مع
العام المقبل أيضًا وتحتاج أيضًا إلى تحقيق
نجاح كبير وآمل أن يكون حلمنا
أن يكون يومًا ما  مهرجان حيث يمكننا
تقديم منحنا لإنشاء هاتف
اعتقدت أنه سيكون مثالياً ، شكرًا لك
ونأمل أن نرى ذلك يومًا ما
وشانا شكرًا جزيلاً لك شكرًا جزيلاً لك شكرًا
رائعًا
[موسيقى]